this program features live coverage of
an African safari and may include animal
kills and caucuses viewer discretion is
advised this is why the inclement ride
is such a firm favorite
if King Quito
[Music]
it just looks ready for a fight
this is still her territory
[Music]
the boys are here to stay how insane was
that good afternoon and welcome to
another episode of Safari lives where
hopefully we're going to be able to show
you lots and lots of big cats now I'm
actually walking on an exceptionally
large animal pathway and a pathway as
big as this can only mean one thing it
means that this should take us to water
and on a hot day like today I'm
surprised we haven't already bumped into
any elephants however I do know that
there's a leopard by the name of Tandy
and no tracks were coming in this
direction this is the closest closest
watering source so I think we're gonna
hang around here near Gallagher a pan
but the animals have been up to all
sorts of wonderful things this past week
let's go take a look and see what all
the animals were doing the Inca boomer
pride and human guinea sub-adults popped
onto Juma they navigated through the
buffalo herds but were unsuccessful they
then had to move further south in search
of better hunting grounds vasana has
been doing a fair bit of walking he
ventured far north further than where
he'd normally wonder but it wasn't long
before he returned to his usual hangout
10 Ghana demonstrated how important it
is to move around as he patrolled his
territory however he eventually caught
himself a warthog
which means he spent most of his days
moving between his kill and tree house
dad this is where you could quench his
thirst Corki the hyena hasn't had to
move much as the leopards including a
brief sighting of hooker Morey and Tandy
have been in close proximity of her den
and all with meals which she could
potentially scavenge the myra teens have
been battling the rain storms in the
afternoon
I highly doubt waffles and the rest of
the North clan are enjoying this the
Lions of the Mara are thrilled that the
migration is in full swing and they
spend most of their time hunting
wildebeest then taking long necks before
they all get up and do it again well the
leopards are surely busy here and the
sabi sand and well the Lions and the
Mara are still doing all the line things
that they get up to and hopefully David
is gonna be able to find you some of
those big cats out in East Africa
otherwise we've got a Tristan and Sydney
also out I'm going to be giving Tristan
a hand this afternoon and we're gonna be
searching for Tandy and the reason why
we're going to be doing this and working
in this area I think it's probably going
to be easier because Tandy and likes to
walk around in circle serpentines we all
know this so I think that's going to be
the best thing to do this afternoon
right well I'm not exactly sure what
Sydney has managed to farm but it sounds
like there's something lurking around
some trees I have got something hanging
there you can see as we are going up
this was an Impala looking at the colour
and the tricks here comes the lovely
spotted cat this cat is the big Duke of
the Juma this is ting Garner you can see
that he's having he's afternoon meal it
seems like there's been quite a lot of
activities taking place here next to
ting Ghana is also highness a very very
good afternoon and welcome to the
beginning of the Safari live show I am
Sydney former Alma cozy and I am
traveling with Sebastian who is my
camera operator this afternoon we are
lucky already no need for me to
introduce my
plan i've already executed done deal
with my plan here is to ghana
for your questions and comments you can
follow us on youtube chat stream you can
also follow us on twitter hashtag safari
live so you can see that the hyena there
is waiting and the tree for small pieces
of mates to fall down
oh it's winning i can hear is crushing
some bones a half of bread is better
than nothing is still eating these
caucus has been here for the past a
couple of hours it has been here since
yesterday morning and it is this Impala
which is benefiting feeding do which has
been feeding three different big cats
husana was here we saw on focus here now
is ting ana it's just that the
competition is too high for the other
case now we've got the big one so now
let's go to tristan who is also about to
kick-start his game drive indeed we are
Sydney we are out and about looking
around to see what we can find and as
you can see we are a tree house damn and
now the reason we're a tree house damn
is obviously because the way Sydney is
sitting with that Impala carcass and
ting gana it's not very far away and
there was a number of other lipids that
were around there in the last couple
days and so we thought we'd check here
in case anyone's come for water as
suddenly mentioned my name is Justin on
camera I've got viens afternoon and it
is a very very beautiful day and so
hopefully we're going to get lucky with
one of our spotted cats be on the
lookout for husana I'm not sure if he is
still around where Sydney is at the
moment Sydney says he'll keep me updated
so you know try and see if we can find
him I thought he might have come down
for a little bit of water and just tried
to see if he can get some kind of
thirst-quenching done but it's quite
interesting with this carcass because
that carcass has been there for two days
now and it's been fairly kind of
overcast and cold and there's not really
been much happening but
what you find when lipids on a carcass
it will be hosted up then it will come
down and we'll go and have water and go
back and forth from the carcass quite
regularly like we saw it in Ghana on his
warthog kill earlier in the week but now
what we're seeing is because there's
been multiple different leopards there
it seems that there's not one track for
a lipid coming and drinking at shiaas
dam and it's probably because they're
all too scared to leave their carcass
because the one is going to steal it
from the others so at the moment it's a
stalemate and it seems as though that
means none of them were actually coming
to drink I was secretly hoping though
that we were gonna come down to this
water point and maybe find him for cars
he just lying here having a bit of a
race with a nice big full tummy but it
doesn't seem like that's the case and I
haven't found any tracks for him so far
from where he was last night at the
carcass I wonder which way he actually
ended up being chased maybe he ended up
it's kind of running further away or he
might still be in that area just
watching from a long distance ting Ghana
seemed quite alert and was looking
around quite a lot this morning and so I
wonder if maybe just maybe that leopard
is still somewhere close by so we'll
keep a lookout we're gonna do a few
little loops around here you're also
gonna try and see if we can hit up a bit
for the north and try and find Tandy and
Columba this afternoon with the help of
potato and walk so that's the kind of
plans lots and lots of spotted plans for
the afternoon hopefully we'll get some
sort of success at some point but it is
a glorious day compared to this morning
which was windy and miserable and cloudy
we now have beautiful sunshine it's
clear there's a bit of a breeze blowing
that's still quite cool but otherwise it
is the most perfect conditions to be
arts on a safari and so hopefully we are
going to get lots that's going to happen
during the course of the afternoon it
should be an exciting one now talking
about hopping a Taylor mckenna on
bushwalk Taylor is busy kind of moving
about and I think she's trying to find
the last tracks that I had of Tandy and
let's see how she's going
well we've come down to a beautiful
drainage system at the moment which is
full with taker and Stan walk and a lot
of well kudu in yalla Bush back so I'm
hoping that they might give us a hand
but I also think that's probably why
tiny has come into this area she doesn't
just have to hunt for herself must
remember that sandy has a youngster now
she's almost a sub-adult so she's
actually the last time I saw her she was
about half the size of Tandy she's she's
grown since then and from the pictures
that I've been seeing she's not much
well shorter than her mother so well
Tandy's got to work a little bit harder
than she had to a couple of months ago
now that young telomere is growing and I
suppose something like a deck or a stand
book which is a very small Angelou isn't
really going to be much for the two of
them so coming down over here like I
said lots of bushbuck lots of in yalla
and Tandy has proven herself time and
time again in tackling well prayed much
much larger than she is I remember once
a few years ago when she'd actually
taken down a fully grown water bath car
by herself which is just unbelievable to
think but anyways so she's come
searching through here and well
something else that Tandy has to do
quite often McClellan burr is go looking
for her daughter
leaving only tracks behind the last few
days
Sydney finally managed to catch up with
Tandy between the pesky flies yang
calamba who refuses to listen when
called and the scorching temperatures
Tandy's patience is wearing thin
especially when a hyena shows up on the
scene and in typical hyena fashion
they'd manage to scavenge the remains of
something
sandy continued to call Columbo while
simultaneously snarling at the
inquisitive hyena darkness fell over the
sabi sand and Tandy continued to search
for her daughter
so nothing just yet on attendees tracks
but where is her number how crazy is
that I can't believe that as Kleber has
gotten older and older her listening
skills have gotten worse normally they
should improve but anyways from what
Tristan said to me it seems like Salama
and Sandy were reunited so there's no
need to worry about that and the her
tracks were some ways just a little to
the east of us that's it rain each time
there's a road called got a path line
she was down that side and has come this
way so that's good news because we know
we're young Cal EMA was left hopefully
and I'm sure she is safe and sound may
be racing up in a tree somewhere in a
drainage line I'm hoping that if we do
pick up on time these tracks will either
see them going back towards claw lumber
which will be great too because then
that means that she's potentially caught
something throughout the day
or maybe they just keep coming this way
then we're really gonna have our work a
set out for us but that's okay we'll
just get on the move and keep on
marching along until we hopefully get to
the well the last footprints but any
lipids are plaguing the minds of the
guides here in the sabi sand they are
for Sydney and well let's go and see
what is happening a little bit further
south from where we are
I look at that you can see that this cat
is still feeding here and thank you very
very much to all the viewers who
rectified my wrong identification as
this is not thing Ghana
this is asana having something to eat
there but now let's go and sit in Ghana
who is also not very far away from where
I am certain Ghana is the one I was
looking for when I got here and then I
thought it was him I was up in the tree
so I can see that Tenggara is right here
and it's not worried by anything is just
very much relaxed right here
so you can see that 10 Ghana is just
resting under a some shade damn the tree
that is resting under does not even have
leaves he's just lying on some of the
branches giving you some shade we did
see him when we got here it seems like
Mpho Kazi moved off maybe back to where
he was coming from I am not too sure
where exactly focus he was from but I
saw that according to their records is
an animal which is occurring much more
towards Manila tea and buffers walk and
also sometimes comes here in Juma you
can see that is the nose that made me to
have a confused so now let's see what
ting Ghana has been doing during the
week something interesting has happened
at in Ghana never want to miss out an
easy meal set patiently on a termite
mound in a flesh alleged onto a
screaming what Rob it was too late for
this prey to react his long canines are
still sharp enough to penetrate the
thick skin despite is all age
after a dusty Dumble this big cat
managed to quickly subdue his prey and
that was one of the best sightings to
Tristan who was very lucky to see this
kind of an old cat taking down an animal
with such a very thick skin his tooth
are still very much sharp and strong in
order to open that very thick skin for
they for the Warthog I think it was
Steve who was so lucky not Tristan my
apologies
look at that so you can see this animal
when is the next act it you cannot even
think that is the one who was catching
the hatak it doesn't look like is the
same animal he is still very strong
so now let's go back to Tristan always
looking at something I am looking at
China so I'm busy trying to check all
the dwarfs points in case there's
something going on and actually what we
found even though it's not one of our
cap characters is very very interesting
because it's two birds that have started
to arrive for the summer now I was
painting it's a lot of our migratory
birds arriving we've really had the
Warburg's eagles but now they're in
front is a green shank that is arrived
this is the first green shank that I've
seen in a long long long long long time
which is very very cool and then off to
the right and down a little bit is
another bird that is a marsh Sandpiper
so there's the marsh Sandpiper that is
busy moving around as well now both of
these birds are migratory and they move
from winter and they go further away and
then in summer they come down into these
areas and they'll be hoping that
there'll be a little bit more water than
what there is now because it's gonna
make life very tricky for them you can
also see that they are impala around and
so that would be the reason why we
coming to these water points is because
it's this time of the day that a number
of animals come and drink and often the
Predators will make use of that
particularly because it's not that hot
this afternoon it's not blisteringly hot
like we've had during the course of the
week it's actually fairly cool for this
time of the day and so we might see some
of the predators taking advantage of
that and potentially trying to stalk
around now Kimberly you say wow it looks
dry it is the driest that I have seen
twin dams since I have been with Safari
live and that means that you know we
really are looking for rain you can see
how the mud is starting to crack it's
it's quite desperate and if we don't get
rain and I would say the next probably
two weeks and we continue to have hot
temperatures like we have this will
probably dry out completely and we'll
just have crack mud which is really
quite sad it's its main reason why we're
not seeing a lot of the elephants and
buffalo herds that we often do see down
in this part of the reserve is because
the water is really just trying out this
is not enough water to sustain an
elephant herd at all you might find the
mud wallow here but they won't drink
this and so it's going to be a bit
desperate for a number of our animals to
actually find the water that they need
in order to survive so it's going to be
a tough time ahead hopefully we get some
rain soon one big storm and this will
fill up quite nicely it's a good
catchment section so
it's really very very very dry at the
moment now I believe I need to send you
somewhere I'm not sure exactly where but
they do have a warthog and hopefully
this one is alive well we've come across
a small family of warthogs I can just
see one at the moment but I thought I
saw some others further back now
visiting Ghana and also a bit by the
name of Hawker mori have mastered the
art of taking down warthogs and this is
a female and we're obviously quite a
distance away and she's quite suspicious
that we're over here you can see how
she's staring in our direction
I did actually stand on a small branch
which she may have heard definitely some
things caught her attention whether it
was maybe the sight of us moving around
or she heard us not sticking oh no
actually trying to get a bit of position
I thought she was gonna walk off just
trying to see if she gets a different
angle so this is what we're doing right
now is behaving exactly like predators
we're not moving we're standing very
very still and that's exactly what a
leopard would do at Ravenna it's always
safe archer even though there's a new
leopard around we probably won't pass
the whole bunch of episode on't even
know that they're there so you don't
have to worry about that that doesn't
that doesn't change anything at all and
he'll probably run away from us I doubt
he's been walked very much see this pig
is still looking at us now they don't
have the greatest sensors unfortunately
their eyesight is what were you not
their best I think they rely on their
nose in their hearing as they're sort of
prominent sensors see not Sean though is
it there's something here but doesn't
know what it is and even though I don't
necessarily want to eat this warthog
it'll still run away from us it's not as
relaxed as a group of Impala probably
because it's on its own maybe it's a
young ball actually mother turned away
just head didn't have put in their own a
stick with my guns what did you think
female traces of male craig said a male
he concedes what the camera zoomed in I
do not have the camera zoomed in
probably about 80 metres away from it
it's all very young male then as he turn
there we go very very young stuff still
had very long wispy white whiskers which
typically the female have match sort of
more prominent white whiskers and the
ball through the balls obviously get the
really big tusks so he must be maybe has
just recently left his family group
could just see you didn't white tusks
kind of sticking out and they'll get
bigger get dangerous exceptionally shot
so even though if it might have the
upper hand in terms of being able to be
quite stealth like that but a sharp
claws and very sharp teeth and needs to
be careful and so did the leopards
because lipids can indeed get hurt right
well Sydney of course is having a great
afternoon already and ting Garner's
around as I'm pretty sure he'd probably
want to eat what we were just looking at
I look at that tail this tail can go
long up to 65 to 90 200 centimetres so
it's one of the very much important tool
for these animals to have a balance when
they are climbing these very big trees
so you can see that the impala this
animals were feeding on it's a good
thing I think that Impala was too big
there's no need for Tenggara to defend
it maybe can only defend a caucus way he
lost quite a lot of energy during the
chase but this was just food for free on
both asana and ting gana so there's no
need for them to fight
so you can see that this leopard might
move at any time to the nearest
waterhole I can see that is very thirsty
but the tummy is looking very very big
at the moment so that was quite a very
big impala so now let's go back to
Tristan who is now driving I'm not too
sure where he is in the reserve well I
mean the man watching at the moment
Sydney and that's because we are trying
to find our queen in this area we're
trying to look for Tandy I know that she
was tracks way around Gallagher pan but
I think in all likelihood she left
Colombo of Tyre Gallagher I mean sorry
Gary Catlin and so I'm wondering if
maybe if I just do the move artsy up
towards kind of niala Road just check
that she hasn't maybe come back it
seemed like she was hunting this morning
and so just double-checking that she's
maybe not moved back into this area and
is actually kind of moving about in the
shade of the Milwaukee and maybe
potentially even hunt him down here she
often comes this way when she is trying
to hunt she'll move into these sections
and she'll kind of stalk around in these
thickets that's what we're going to look
for there's no sign of room for cars he
going to triage or two twin dams didn't
pick up anything crossing filaments cut
line so in all likelihood you must have
at some point gone over Weaver's nest
and maybe headed a little bit more to
the sort of southeast and so that's also
part of the reason why I want to drive
the Milwaukee here because I'll pick up
his tracks very quickly if he came
southeast the kill wait seven years at
the moment is directly to my north west
at the moment and so it's a straight
line towards where we are now would be
about right so that's why we checking
around here this is a big pathway that's
you find lipids often used but there's
no tracks for a lipid today Crossing
there's also not tracks that we're
looking for so just lots of antelope
tracks in the mall RT which is as far as
fini what do you expect it at end of the
day it's a great place for a lot of the
antelope species to be able to spend a
lot of time now there is a warthog over
there it's just got its back side
towards us hidden around now I'm pretty
sure the warthogs at the moment are
hating the fact that it is so dry at the
moment because well there's really no
way for them to hide and they keep
getting caught art by these lipids as
they try and kind of make their way back
to their mounds and the sort of dust of
them going in and out of Mars is very
easy for a liquid to spot and so they
are sure hoping for a little bit more of
rain to come there'll also be a lot of
them will be pregnant now and be having
their little ones soon you normally
start to see them around October which
is I suppose a lipids kind of candy
store times and it's going to be really
really interesting to see if husana is
going to try and hunt warthogs at this
time of the year these little piglets
because he's gonna have to start
graduating as a male liquid and start
kind of going off turtle piglets it's
something that won't mail lipids do
quite regularly and so he's going to
have to learn that too last year he
didn't so I'm quite interested to see
this year if he does now talking about
her sauna and learning things he
obviously has a very clever clever mind
because this week he showed just how
clever and cunning he can be as he slunk
into an opportunity of a meal an older
male leopard by the name of whom for
cars he showed up on Juma we spotted him
from a distance in a military with an
Impala kill he seemed to be quite shy
and dashed on the tree had vanished into
thin air next asana who had been
watching from a distance seized the
opportunity to steal his kill
hyena arrived in full force and lingered
below the tree hoping for a few scraps
asana then repositioned the kill it's
one of the higher branches with absolute
ease he was lucky he didn't lose the
kill he had stolen - the true scavengers
down below well wasn't that absolutely
incredible it's amazing to see how
hisana has learnt a lot from the past
few months we know that the past few
months he's had a lot of issues with
Tenggara and tiny stealing his kills and
he's I'm sure learned some valuable
lessons from that and what he's probably
learned is that if a carcass is
unattended well it's anyone's game and
say he ran in there and managed to feed
and he used the fact that the other male
leopard had moved off
hyenas were about and the hyenas would
probably have kept that other male
leopard at bay to a degree to be
opportunistic enough to get himself a
really good meal so very very clever
from husana and it just goes to show
that he's slowly but surely starting to
learn how to become an adult male
leopard and really hard to look after
himself the only problem is is that he
needs to be very careful with doing
those kind of things other bigger male
leopards like the likes of huka Murray
or Anderson probably wouldn't be nearly
as sort of tolerance and also probably
wouldn't have been nearly as shy of the
vehicles and therefore wouldn't have
opened that opportunity but if he's
gonna rush in like that he's gonna have
to be very very careful and make sure
that he's paying attention interestingly
enough though he's obviously still
fairly kind of wary of other leopards
because he managed to not get a single
scratch or scar on him with this whole
altercation with him for Kazi didn't get
in any way kind of seems as though I
didn't get physically hurt by him in any
way or in remotely get close to him and
so he still knows that he needs to be a
little bit careful in his kind of
behavior around dad and Tandy he's very
different than it is around her Komori
and potentially other leopards and so
you know with him for kasi he was a lot
more aware of what was going on but she
saw the gap and bolted upright and got
himself a really good meal so very very
very clever from hassan and he's going
to need those techniques later in life
if he is to succeed and to be able to
find food regularly and it's part of a
lipids kind of modus operandi they
and they do steal from many others and
they will steal from females they're
still from younger males like Hassan has
happened to him with ting gana
and so you know it's important that he
learns how to go about it and where and
when is the right times to do it
especially now while he's still quite
young so it's gonna be interesting to
see if he tries it again with other
lipids he's still obviously very very
kind of wary of ting I can see now even
with Sydney in this afternoon that ting
honestly is the boss at the moment and
he wouldn't try I don't think do that
with ting gana being around but you
never know the two of them have a unique
relationship and that means that they
kind of end up doing all kinds of things
that are unusual and unique so watching
ting Ghana and husana together is a very
special thing and watching him interact
with other lipids is very very
intriguing and such a stretch of special
character that I'm so glad we have him
around
James D he backed off a bit more than he
could chew unfortunately poem for Kazi
killed that Impala in really the worst
possible place he killed it kind of dead
center of Jummah and that meant that the
two sausages in the form of hassan and
tin gana we're not going to let that
pass at all and so poor kind of info
kasi and eventually unfortunately had to
kind of give it up to both sausage 2.0
first and then sausage 1.0 in the form
of ting goners so it wasn't a great
place for him to have killed it and
being sort of more nomadic smaller
leopard in many respects then somebody
like ting garnet made it sort of a bit
of a difficult time for him anyway he's
niala are going to kind of disappear at
us now shortly so we're going to send
you across to David up in the Mara and
he's looking around all over the place
I'm sure for maybe they'll win your
pride and hopefully he's had a bit of
luck a very good afternoon and hello
everyone wherever you are in the world
and welcome to a sunset Safari Drive all
the way in Kenya and we're in the Mara
triangle two vultures to start our drive
today and I'm sure most of you have been
wondering why I have been my name has
never changed David always and luckily
manual camera today
good morning Manu oh very good I thought
Mary's asleep you might have one been
wondering where we have been we have
been having some technical issues and
you got a gentleman who is very handsome
by the name of Edwin and we tried for
him to come on the camera to say hi he
refused him all of you know Conrad in
South Africa I think both of them are
very handsome
anyhow remember this is a very
interactive Safari your questions are
very much welcome any comments you may
have please send it through as usual
hashtag safari live don't forget to
follow us also on a YouTube chat stream
as zebras are walking through there
the migration still very solid in the
Mara triangle and this is just a small
hard of what maybe we'll be seeing much
later we could loads and loads of
wildebeest and zebra around this time
around
I'm not very far from where we are when
we were fixing our problem we saw more
vultures apart from the fast to weave we
showed you we saw a lot more elsewhere
and a different different species of
vultures sorry I'm pleased you may have
to come bring a question again tell me
where you are
answering or you asking thirty be the
hottest country in Africa well it
depends on the time of AR as they move
on we'll try and go closer to that
little rough area it depends on what
country terrible you are talking about
for me I would say to the north of Kenya
to the north of the equator as you go
towards say Egypt Morocco those
countries in general are always very hot
and they have a lot of desert like you
know I would say habitats but as you
come south of the equator towards South
Africa and not of course all the areas
green but you're a lot cooler here I
would say Namibia sometimes gets very
hot but for me I'd say north of Africa
Egypt Morocco and those countries for
the north are pretty hot if not much
close that to the vultures will be so
from a distance how is that man who I
just want to point out these voters
because they're very special for so many
reasons
we've got different species of vultures
in East Africa in Kenyan particular we
got seven to voltar's this one is the
largest in size while all the other
world just go in big groups or in big
flocks or 15 20 sometimes 50 this one's
only go in twos and my guess is always a
male and a female you'll keep watching
that as I try to dig out my book and
this one is called the Nubian vulture or
the lappet-faced vulture Nubian vulture
a lappet-faced vulture it is the largest
in size and also the strongest vulture
that we have in Kenya not sure it's very
warm for it because the thing is trying
to cool off by opening the wings they
are and if you're lucky to see the head
you'll notice the head is bald doesn't
have any feathers covering it we'll just
wait a few seconds and see well yes look
at the hair there and notice unlike the
other six species of vultures this one
is always bald hopefully you'll be able
to see the other one but in the meantime
let's find out what's in Ghana is doing
you can see now that the tip of the nose
here is very very dark and this is how
is the distinguish between the two but
this afternoon I made a mistake because
the nose for hasanah
is full of blood and the blood shades
the color I couldn't manage to organize
or sauna very well so look at that you
can see the colors here by the stomach
looks completely different from the head
so the head is gold and the underneath
the stomach is much more white
so he looks very tired at the moment
this cat has been feeding a lot last
week he is not scavenging here because
he is hungry
so now let's see some of the displays
which were done by ting Ghana after
having a warthog on the menu dealing
with a warthog is not an easy exercise
on the menu after a long hot day of
feeding on his wa talk ting ghana went
to the nearest waterhole to quench a
thirst as the Sun set when he got there
he settled in for a long drink with his
stomach full at the heat of the day was
still beating down and this big cat
couldn't manage the long walk back to
his kill and so he lay down close by
before his digestive system to reduce
its massive stomach and wait for the
heat of the day to pass the very strong
skin they have got to go to the nearest
holes and drink water he was battling to
find space in order to get water in
there as the stomach was looking very
very big and then later just decided to
light there so that he can lose weight a
little bit it seems like he's listening
to me ma the big cat is indeed everybody
likes the big cats
indeed so I hope he's gonna wake up now
and go back to the caucus and show us
some of the activities as now is just
resting but I'm gonna leave him now and
see if we can have a better sighting of
Isana
so I can see it's very much sitting so
now let's go back to the bush walk where
teyla is also looking for something
interesting so we've managed well I
haven't but her be here of courses on
bush walk with us this afternoon has
managed to pick up on Tandy and son
Amber's tracks so that could mean one of
two things that could mean that Tandy
has made a kill she's bringing Columbia
here or she was just moving a little bit
further wasted North and thought that it
was a bit far away that you drop Lima
that such she's going to fetch her and
put her in another safe spot now our
tracks came in this direction and they
were going towards one of two termite
mounds this was one of them and then
there's another one just to the right of
us so we trying to figure out which
termite man she would have used as a
vantage point and I think it's a good
idea that she does it here because it's
fairly open but with all the fallen
trees and things around like that just
standing up on higher ground would
definitely give her a better advantage
she does forever to see down and on the
other side of some of these fallen logs
and at the moment they're calm and ache
and the stand book are using them for
cover they're kind of hiding around so
often when you see like an area like
this this is a Vash Rolo and you'll see
a Dakers sort of just curled up here
just sitting in the corner camouflaged
using the the tree to its advantage or
the standing over yeah they come this
way could all these spots just laying in
amongst here with perhaps just ears and
things sticking out it's a really really
good spot so she wants to be careful
about it she wants to make sure that she
sneaks around canopies of that again I'm
so sorry I didn't get the beginning part
of the question ah now say my name and
no I don't think hollering 10d would be
beneficial it would be very beneficial
to the people doing research on her
however for us I think a caller can be a
bit of a hinderance sometimes to the
animals species something like a leopard
so you know it's best to leave them
office this is a lot more fun it's
finding animals this way sorry
something's caught my eye but I think
it's just a bra
that's dangling it looks like an animal
hanging from a tree but I don't think it
is I think it's just the branch it's
maybe broken and so if I don't think I'd
actually ever work on a reserve where
there are constantly tracking the
Predators to be able to find them there
takes a lot of the fun out of it the the
art and skill that comes with tracking
is exceptional and so it's all about
that experience so if we were to just
jump on the GPS and be able to go yeah
cool that's very tiny year's get a
little bit boring don't you think you
literally just be driving to a garret
and actually no it's not a guaranteed
sighting because when I was down in the
Eastern Cape they had colors on the
black rhinos and every time the ng
poaching team would try and check where
they are sometimes they knew exactly
were the web at the vegetation or
something was was too thick or the
terrain you were unable to be drive on
it these things that have limited to you
seeing them so even though he did have
colors us but it wouldn't guarantee a
society again it takes the fun out of it
and then it's just it's I think it's
it's boring and unstimulating to be
perfectly honest so I'm quite glad that
the animals a dirt have any colors on it
and luckily for us the tunic had you
been watching our uncoloured and having
a great Sunday afternoon you can see now
that hasana is just dropping everything
from the tree now
so these highness are so very much
patients they are not worried even if
it's taking two days they know that food
is gonna come so now you can see that
they are having their time now so high
up there we have got a Hosanna who is
trying to get something
Nik as time goes on asana is going to
get quite a lot of justice a lot level
and mostly that happens when they catch
oh there's something going on here is
quite an interesting competition at the
moment so these kinds of of cats when
they are older than four years is when
they start to challenge each other for
the territory so there are possibilities
of this little person achieve to fight
against in Ghana to take over as time
goes look at that now you can see these
animals are chasing each other and one
of them is just coming from the
waterhole I can see he has been resting
maybe it's coming from down there by the
twins Dam so this is what is called a
intraspecific competition when you find
the species of the same species fighting
for the same food source so that one is
looking high up there still hoping
something is gonna come so this one was
lucky because he's dealing with a skull
now so the whole skull just got landed
and he managed to grab it so quickly
so you can hear them breaking is kind of
bones so these animals they've got a
very rushed nearly high in a sound when
they are communicating is interesting
and they've got different calls it's
amazing listening to them
I love hyenas look at that that one is
thinking is just saying unfortunately I
don't have right equipment to climb this
tree but if I had I was gonna come up
there is the one who did not manage to
get a piece when these small pieces were
falling from this tree
I see now this little chip is just a
feeding on some of the lexicon say if
it's the front or the hind legs but now
it's just dealing with the air Lex is
trying to open everything and it's
becoming very difficult that's why he's
battling to all these killer because
he's just now trying to get something
from the legs I don't think there is
much left there you see you think is
good all four legs at the same time they
might end up living but I don't think
ting ganas gonna challenge asana for
what is left now unless maybe ting ghana
wants to go and verify if indeed there
is nothing left now at that caucus so
you can see now he is just licking the
bones
so now let's go back to Tristan Oh is
now driving somewhere around the
Milwaukee area
I am indeed we still trying to see if we
can find any signs of Italian Colombian
with obviously you he's got the tracks
where he is so we're a little bit behind
and we need to try and get around him
and try and cut off suits and blocks to
try and help them a little bit so we're
heading in that direction at the moment
and hopefully we will have a little bit
of luck in you know we were kind of
checking around Gary cut line because we
weren't sure if maybe this is where
Colombo was left but now that hermes for
trucks for both it's gonna help us a lot
because we can kind of get around that
area and hopefully we'll be able to find
these two somewhere in that it's a very
very tricky section that's Herbie's in
at the moments is big undulating
drainage lines which is perfect for a
leopard but not ideal for us and our
vehicles our vehicles do not get in
there very well at all and so we're
gonna hope that they've kind of maybe
just skirted and either lying up on the
banks or they at least in an open
section that we can actually access and
get to you so and we haven't have a
tricky find I think that the best baits
is probably Herbie and Taylor and then
finding in football we kind of just
skirt the edges and hope that they don't
cross over the road so that's what we
gonna do we're gonna close or blocks
hope that we can help them in that way
what's nice about today is that they've
dragged the roads you can see the roads
in front so smooth smooth smooth so
they've taken tires just to level
everything up this is what we the wall
Rickson actually does most of this and
so he kind of cleans up the surface of
the roads because they get a little bit
bumpy with all the vehicles and let's
just put sand in all the little holes
and keeps the roads in good condition
it's just so happens that it's really
useful for when we're tracking it kind
of cleans the roads so nicely it makes
tracks really easy to see and so we know
if they've walked over areas that have
been dragged well there's a fresh tracks
from during the course of this afternoon
which will be very helpful indeed so I'm
hoping
and she finds these two mavens now when
you saw with Sydney that's hasana is
busy dropping bits of meat and feeding
the local hyena population well he's had
a few disagreements with him this week
and it's all part and parcel of his
learning curve a familiar figure of a
cat in a tree greeted us as dawn broke
it was Hassan and safely stashed his
kill happy with its position he
descended to wrist the thud of his
landing attracted the waiting hyenas
vasana clearly irritated by the arrival
slunk towards the tree he growled and
gave a small charge an attempt to see
off his pesky enemy iana promptly
retreated leaving a growling asana at
the base of the tree well persona is a
tough win these lots of hyenas around
but he certainly does front up he's
quite brave for a young leopard I mean
you must remember he's only two two
years and eight months old he's not
exactly a very big male leopard and
intimidating and imposing just yet but
he's got that confidence and kind of
bravery in him and that he'll often try
and take on our you know one on one the
thing is those as soon as it gets more
than that he's learnt that he's got to
get out of there and try and kind of
move off but I was quite impressed with
him is amazing to kind of watch him
hissing and snarling and actually even
charging a little bit at those hyenas in
a way of telling them back off this is
my tree with my kill I don't want you
here so he really is kind of being good
about it and and he's he's learned a lot
but he used to kind of cower away from
them whereas now he's gonna eventually
kind of get to that big male leopard
attitude where it's like I will
challenge you if it's for food but he's
just still clever enough to know that
more than one is a very dangerous thing
it was sort this morning with him is
that he actually you know had a bit of a
hissing match with a one eye in a little
in Timnath and then as soon as another
one arrived to you is not having any of
it and moved
towards the base of another tree that he
could then escape so he knows that he's
gotta get towards escape routes and
trees and that's always very very very
interesting and I think what happened
there with that particular sighting is
that hasana
probably the reason why it was a little
more aggressive than he normally is is
that that hyena got to the point that it
was escape his escape route so there
wasn't too many other trees around bear
and so he kind of pushed that her I know
way so that if I into charge at him he
could then get up into that marilla and
get to safety so it was a very clever
maneuver by Hasan and like I say he is a
cunning cat and he's learned lots of
valuable things over the course of this
winter in his short little life is kind
of progressing a much faster than some
others given him last time that he had
to spend on his own so it's amazing to
kind of watch him go about his business
and his instinct is really very very
good right we're going to try and like I
say Hobart Taylor and Herbie and the
best way for us to do that is to go past
calico pan and in shoot up Gallagher's
shortcut and in this little road that
links up to the fire break and that's
probably where ton D if she does go
anyway is going to head and so that's
where we're going to try and help out
and see what we can find in the meantime
though and it sends you back across to
David in the Maasai Mara I'm glad that
his tech issues have been sorted and
it's always good to have him with us
well it's time for celebration - most of
the cuts as we have seen Hosanna but
also the Lions here in the Mara triangle
celebrating loss will be students in the
background and I think one of them early
today as you can see was brought down
not sure what time these two females did
that but most likely it crab in mid
morning they brought down one of the we
list of the many thousands we got well
this happens a lot this time around for
the migration and if there could be a
male here he could easily come and
intimidate these two girls and he'll
tend to eat until he is full twelve to
allow them to eat now what I'm talking
about is in the bush here males will
always display dominance even amongst
themselves
Kapali arrived to survey his territory
only to find two unwanted guests one
brezin enough to mate with button ups a
female from the winner pride Kapoor Lee
zeroed in on one of the nomadic males
and made quick work of the short-tailed
fellow just seeking far and away out of
his sight late in the afternoon ki
pulley returned to deal with the second
intruder the and nomads charged that key
pulley to protect his prize but she
chose to leave the gentlemen to square
out their differences the duel was
heated but brief the young inexperienced
Nomad was no match for the seasoned
veteran Kapoor Lee returned to his stuff
but not returned as well immediately
offering herself to the victim the
amorous pea spent the rest of the day
together doing their best to create the
next generation of these iconic cuts of
the Mara well that was a very epic epic
epic in the sense that to show dominance
on that one particular male you saw
there was a bigger men that we call ki
Puli Puli translates to if you look
carefully on his loss his nose the right
side has a small slit that's why we call
him Kapoor Lee and Coppola is a loco
Swahili word now these two boys here
seemed to be just drugged in these
crackers and eating it and what Kapali
did there on that fight I have noticed
males in general will fight for two
reasons either number one for mating
rights and especially the Lions or for
food Sookie Puli this particular time
was meeting with two other males for
breeding right on that one female there
that we call butternut and that
particular female as I said there comes
from a proto Ryan's
code the enos and it showed you that
Kapoor Lee still has many days to rein
in his stuff and he is still very in
charge
now we've got two young boys here which
is does devouring this wildebeest and I
think as I said earlier they brought it
down most likely mid morning and my
guess is they belong to a particular
pride of lions that we call the Oh Lala
knows and chances are they might have
been shown the door and boys at
particular age to two and a half
they'll be told you know go leave your
life get your own wives get you on a
territory and I think they're doing well
because this second time I'm seeing them
with a kill on their own they have
always been depending or the whole pride
to get food for themselves please
remember this is a very interactive
Safari Drive we do here
so should you have any questions or any
comments send them over so to the left
there you can see these another boy and
a youngster - he must have eaten earlier
and have been resting on the shade
because of the heat of the day and I'll
show the grass kava is helping him and
that Bush Chris from the look of this
which to me doesn't look bad and I can
tell you until tomorrow this will color
the moon until tomorrow maybe the day
after
you know Lions Chris are very good in
energy saving so I think they'll stick
on this will be it looks like to me it
wasn't an adult fully grown one and if
you look at the size of the ribs there
they don't look very large for like a
fully grown will be I'm talking of a
mass of 250 kilograms or about 600
pounds over prey so to me those ribs
look at this that is smaller and it
might cut them another two three days
now let's find out what the other
predator is doing in South Africa you
can see now that the hyenas they're
enjoying everything on the ground
suddenly Sanne managed to drop the whole
kill he doesn't have anything at the
moment it's only the hyenas having
something
so their anuses are well-equipped with
the truth which are strong enough in
order to deal with this legs both front
and hind legs they are just crashing the
bones here and quite a lot of
competition is going on yet fighting a
lot for these remains so you can see
that now it seems like Hasan is trapped
as the hyenas are feeding right under
the tree it's time for asana now to
clean himself you can see that is
starting to leak his front leg so that
he can clean his face and also clean
everywhere
where is Platt you can see that the
blood is just everywhere around the toes
in the class
if this cat don't clean this kind of
blood it is going to sting and the prey
are going to sniff him from a distance
it's time for grooming now so now let's
go to Taylor oh god as ever we have
indeed got feathers and I didn't kill
this bird so I wonder who devoured this
feathered creature now with the
footprints that we've been seeing of
Tandy and Phil Americana tells a story
and my immediate thought is that Columba
is practicing her hunting skills and
well of course an unsuspecting death
which it kind of looks like that's what
it was very gray feathers and then we
look at a wing that I have in my hand to
mean that kind of screams a Turtledove
maybe it could also be a red idea it
could be either one of the two but one
of them quartered and like I said
something so small I don't know it would
really catch the attention of Tony I
think Donna her days where she plays
around like a kitty cat
but Columbia on the other hand she would
have had an absolute field day now
the tracks are going up and down in the
drainage line and back out the other
side so we're just kind of sussing out
what's going on and where we should go
from here on our nightly show in the
last time Colombo was seen on camera
I've I haven't seen tiny autónoma once
since I've been back so I think it's
been a couple of weeks now but we know
she's around because we're seeing three
sets of tracks so even though we're not
necessarily getting to capture her all
the time at least we know that she's
still alive and she's doing well I
suppose that is the most important thing
now you were all very worried the other
day and those hyenas were eating the
scraps of something and you know it was
just a coincidence
Tandy he was calling to lumber and she
wouldn't come out of it maybe Panama was
a bit nervous of the hyenas she didn't
want to be around them well children
blame poor Craig is now trying to duck
and dive we trapped let's go this way
gotta try and avoid some of the trees
okay well we're going to keep on
searching around yeah as you can manage
and hopefully we'll also be able to find
a liquid this afternoon you can see that
now an asana still here by the tree and
on the ground the security is very tight
he doesn't want to come down so this
chair this cat has been experiencing
quite a lot of challenges earlier this
week
let's see how he has been experi skips
experiencing things
it was Ana's unattended Kiera the scent
of asana still lingering meant he was
not interested in the kill but read
awaited force Ana's retain the to has
been seen once before where asana had
made a hasty retreat this encounter was
not different as Okamura spotted an
unsuspecting hassan hassan unluckily had
enough of headstart and using all his
speed managed to an early escape the
charging of Kumari witnessing a sighting
like this is very much array this kind
of big cats they do challenge each other
for territorial purposes what we saw it
was I'm sure a territorial fight is just
that the husana is not yet ready to
retaliate when it comes the territorial
activities
Ivy on the ground that is true the
security is very very tight indeed I
have got three highness at the moment
and all these writers they are just
everywhere I can see is trying to check
a vehicle is gonna pass but he's going
to be difficult and him and design has
got quite a lot of encounters before so
you can see that is the one who managed
to go away with a big piece and is
trying by all means to defend the other
ones when coming there he's just
fighting look at that so now let's go to
the Maasai Mara with Dave it is very
lucky with the Lions at the moment well
what a timing because they are the boy
he just rose up and I'm sure he wants to
hedge the kid let's find out his berry
looks pretty fool are you having a limp
or just because you've been laying down
you don't seem okay to it boom typical
of lions sleep snooze but this we've got
the brother here who doesn't seem to be
full and hungry and still trying to
shear the meat out of the bones consider
rib cage now and most likely oh the
stomach contents are gone I can see any
really will lions eat the stomach
contents contents
Rosalyn it depends on number one I would
say how clear maybe the wind is the edge
and also say the size of the lion
because we have some males for example
the one you saw earlier that had a fight
code Khopoli and on clear days Goodwin
open area without much obstruction they
can comfortably or you can get them like
even from five miles away five miles
away it's very possible to get Aurora of
a big lion and especially after the
rains what happens after the rain any
scent marking they have done it goes or
when the just sent in the air a little
bit concern of competition of other
males want them to come in they want to
pass the message out and clear there and
then that particular time they are very
loud to make sure the rule goes as far
as possible okay five months eight eight
nine kilometers you can hear for a clear
day lion roar now this one see our
youngsters and I highly doubt maybe they
can do anything that can go over one
mile but be very hungry boy yeah roshni
I'll tell you Puli is the king because
Ali and I'm sure you watched K Puli
sing-off
the youngster there we were there in the
morning and were two males and there
were nomadic males because the tumors we
have never seen before and alimony
we just met when Kapoor Lee was doing
some quick work on the first male and we
have always thought mera huge lazy can't
run but Kapoor Lee gave that other
nomadic lie in a chase we estimate of
about two miles non-stop Ron Ron Ron to
Mars
and of course the nomadic youngster
there was no much to Puli he came back
and he rested under three like 50 meters
away from the other youngster all the
other nomadic male
that was meeting with a butternut female
that comes from the inner pride and this
was in the afternoon and I've been
thinking since that time why didn't he
come straight to the other male he did
not and he chose for us to rest and we
got to meet with a man who the other day
we were thinking well did he stop there
truly a strategy to energize to have a
plan and the moment he wake up Rosaleen
he went straight to that nomadic male
and it's never took him more than 15
minutes to deal with him down dust and
off he went and I agree with you great
comment keep Uli will remain the king of
this area for quite some time
well let's find out what the beautiful
Taylor got now we've got beautiful
trucks handsome David use this now it's
quite windy today so there's the back of
the pad over there here are the toes
what you can see now these are Tandy's
footprints clambers tracks are just
slightly smaller than Herstal now here's
one here's the next pore and then
there's quite a big gap from where she
jumps to next which is over here you can
just sort of see it and then she goes
across over there so that's a pretty big
stride and tandi's not a particularly
large cat so herby has suggested that
she's moving swiftly and those don't
look too old either it's exceptionally
windy so the tracks are being quite
blown and we've been walking now on this
area for a bath I don't know 25 30
minutes just going really really slowly
going back on tracks coming back and
obviously on roads like this it's the
easiest to spot them but with all the
grass sort of dying we've actually been
really lucky we've had a track here and
then you can see how sandy it is sort of
in between the grass now sandy she's
okay on foot she kind of just stays at
you from a distance but we know that
clamber is with her
Kalama is very nervous when I'm is
probably gonna run off when she sees us
she doesn't she doesn't really seem to
be as comfortable and with us on foot
but that's okay
so
I'm glad the Tristan's in the area we've
actually just had a conversation with
Tristan he's gonna loop on around and go
down Galago road and hopefully they're
still in between this block ideally we
want Tristan to find the Leopards before
us because we don't want to keep chasing
Tandy and her number if that's the
reason why they're running is because
they're nervous so we'd rather just have
them pop-art interested and kind of just
gets them that's the idea anyways he
goes party on I'm pretty sure that's a
mother well constantly is telling their
youngster to keep away from danger and
they learn what those well what danger
is they obviously start to listen out
for sounds and things like that you know
if you hear anything running like the
son of a hyena Columbus first reaction
of poverty not to hang around and wait
like maybe mom would would stand and
snarl and assess the situation young to
llama is probably still racing trees or
running away putting as much distance
between her and a potential threat
she knows she's small she's young she
can't really defend herself and to be
honest mom can only do so much
so those natural instincts will also
kick in and of course with mom
constantly mentoring her as she grows
that that is definitely gonna help her
keep safe now like I said Tristan is not
too far away he's just slightly to the
west of us and have probably got some
nice light on the ground which will help
him spot the tracks
well we do indeed it's beautiful light
now perfect time to find Tandy and what
we're basically doing is we found those
tracks that Taylor just showed you as
well and we are a little bit to the
north kind of west of where they are in
the direction that she those tracks are
heading so we're going to try and close
off the block and see and Hobie and I
reckon that we don't think that she's
come out of this block but what I wanted
to show you is something that's quite
interesting we've seen it before and
it'll just show you one more time that
it was would have been nice if maybe
these two leopards that come here just
to investigate it given that this
carcass has dangled in this tree for
well over a year in a bit nicer there is
an Impala carcass that was some reason
left in the tree itself why it was left
in there by whoever put it up I'm not
quite sure you can see how dried is not
literally just bones that are there and
it's really is quite amazing that it's
still kind of intact hanging there's a
bit of skin that must be like leather by
now and that's just dangling now I
wouldn't have been surprised at Columba
who is always quite curious maybe tried
to go and have a little check of it and
go and see what that was but alas no
sign of them here and see any tracks of
them either coming out going northwards
as yet and so I'm hoping that what
they've done is found a termite mound or
something that they're lying on and it
would be very nice if we would be able
to kind of find her on one of those now
talking about carcasses hanging from
trees hasana
as much as he's brave with lioness
unfortunately this week well he wasn't
as good as hoisting and keeping it up in
the tree
after his successful defense against the
hyena in the morning hasana enjoyed the
spoils of his hard-earned meal he
somehow had dropped these kill late in
the afternoon the thoughts of trying to
hoist it back up the tree crossed his
mind but for some reason Mehsana decided
to play with his carcass instead and he
dragged it around getting further from
the tree the noise of his antics was
bound to attract the wrong kind of
attention
hyena looking to level the score barrel
demons Prasanna had no choice but to
abandon his carcass and run looking
pleased with itself the hyena drag the
carcass off to feed the battle was not
over however as hasanah tried under the
cover of darkness to steal his prize
back unfortunately by then hyenas were
having none of it and they sent asanas
scuttling off to watch as the remains of
his kill were devoured to learn some
lessons and we're saying that he's
learnt a lot but he still got some
lessons to kind of continue to learn and
dropping a carcass and that wasting it
straight away once again is one of those
lessons unfortunately for him for some
reason he got it into his mind that he
didn't need to waste it he dragged it
around and played with it a little bit
and then unfortunately lost it which I'm
really not surprised about what
surprised me with that whole thing is
that he had actually seen I you know
before that so it's not like you didn't
know I in his way around maybe he just
thought it wasn't really worth wasting
the kind of bones that were left but he
lost start quite quickly unfortunately
and as soon as more wine has arrived
well there was the end of that for poor
little Hassan and he lost out on his
meal unfortunately but yo I'm hopefully
learned from those and hopefully will
continue to kind of grow and be able to
recognize that when it dropped he needs
to put it back up straightaway
good now we're going to keep moving on
and keep going I didn't copy mo who
exactly you said can you just give me
the name again it would send you
somewhere but I was just waiting
- the little chief himself with Sidney
you can see the little chief has just
attempted to go down from the marula
tree but the security it is still very
much tight on the ground I can see he is
negotiating and what you needed to come
down to the ground here and he seems to
be very difficult he nearly got off the
ground but maybe they are going to give
him a chance to come down and as he did
help them a lot he gave them something
to eat
he must have to do that they must return
a favor it must be very thirsty at the
moment as the Sun is very very hot and
the wind is blowing too much after
having the mill which was caught
yesterday now the meat was not
moisturised anymore
they do have bold trees this is very
much interesting you can see but I can
promise you when he got down here on the
ground it would be very much interesting
he's not gonna go after the signers but
he will come down and just disappear how
he climbed this tree yesterday it was
phenomenal
so it is trying to count the number of
meters from way is to the ground then he
showed that the meters are too much that
is very much I cannot jump to the ground
he must have to go down a little bit and
then jump France is sometimes like what
I saw yesterday let me tell you what I
witnessed yesterday when tingle when
husana went up to this tree after
shortly after the the oomph ocassi ran
away he defecated on on this highness
while he was up trying to pull the heavy
caucus and they just started just
dropping everywhere it was interesting
it says that we miss that but we saw it
happening
so now let's go back to david by the
messiah as he still by the lion sighting
at the moment well husana still reminds
me of what she is capable of doing and
i'm surprised that he is not getting rid
of those hyenas like kapooya did with
invading 2 million stars the other day
well the youngster here from the owner
of pride Alliance for those who've never
joined us before these two they're two
boys here there's one feeling at the
moment and they belonged operator by
owns that we call that oh la laa LAAS he
has been feeling rather long without the
brother I would say and you can see the
brother they're just laying down but
from the look of his belly he is just so
full considered panting on him and most
likely he must have eaten before the
other layer it's always easy for afraid
of lions one it's especially a female
becomes in estrus it always tend to go
away and met with another or male in a
meal in a coalition of lions and then
after meetings over she'll always come
back and rejoin her pride after her
honeymoon with capilene butternut was in
such of the rest of her pride
she called for a while and eventually
stood seeming to have picked a scent in
a up a few minutes passed and our
suspicions were proven correct she
bounded with joy towards her daughter
who seemed less enthused to see her
mother after a few nozzles to reaffirm
their bond the pair settle in for an
afternoon snoozer when we came across
the pride the next day the entire pride
was all together and had managed to cut
a will Vista to celebrate their reunion
the young male now Bay as a superficial
wounds that he acquired while butternut
was away meeting the Marino's fed
throughout the day and would not allow
the vultures to share in a hard-won meal
the relocated the male and brought it
closer where they could keep an eye on
it from the comfort of the shed the
vultures had to settle for the
wildebeest remains proving that nothing
ever goes to waste in the wilderness
now you notice that that's big female
there is called the butternut and she
had gone away to mate with the king of
this area that we call Coulee and as she
came back you'd see how lions tend to
greet each other after Iranian now
butternut has two daughters in that
pride that we call the oh we know pride
and as soon as she came back you know
she was very welcomed as much as the
daughter did not seem very excited I
would imagine she was a bit upset the
mother had been away for quite some time
in the Owen apply there's one young
stout at the same age oh sorry the one
you see on the screen there and one of
the other bigger females in that fight
over we know is the mother of that
youngster and I think butternut is in
the Pathfinder oh the matriarch in that
particular pride and as soon as she went
away the youngster went away to done
I'll tell you male lions to me is little
bit more than the females but the
females getting the same I would say
needs that males have a food drink if
they'll get anything or all what they
want they would tend to sleep as long as
the mayors but in general males tend to
sleep more out in the bush I've found
out femurs when they have a kill they
have eaten enough they have had somewhat
a drink to drink don't sleep as much as
the male's not much of a difference so
saying earlier there's a young star in
the winner's pride the same size as the
one we have here that is just devouring
this particular wildebeest and excuse me
about my hair there I do not know where
this boy is taking this kill and that
hamster in the winner's pride as soon as
the butternut will think could have been
his aunt left he also designed decided
to go out wind around on his own and he
was trying I guess to join another
coalition of males and he was buttoned
and he had no choice but come and rejoin
the pride so
we are trying to follow him or be
looking for in the last few days to see
the improvement or the healing of the
wound not very deep to me they looked
very superficial so he should be able to
heal very quickly but how interesting
that cuts after the finish meeting and
I'm talking about including leopards and
cheetahs once the meetings over and we
assume the female has conceived and the
oldest pathways and the familial is
rejoin her pride and maybe the male well
done there Manu will join the coalition
very good no one reposition here and see
what is particular lion won't do because
I think the vultures are trained to come
come around here and as soon as the
Lions see the vultures they'll tend to
like be alert and gets rid of them in
the meantime as a repositioned let's
find out what other predators Sydney God
this security is now getting more tight
another hind I just arrived now it's
about four Highness under a tree so I
don't think Sanne will be able to come
down now and there is even some
activities happening amongst the
Highness themselves as they are still
challenging each other with regards to
the remaining food but only one amongst
the four is having something to eat at
the moment when these animals are
feeding they can be protective all they
are doing now is protecting what they
have
so you can see now as well that I up
there on a tree
Hosanna is right facing them Jojo the
Highness can hear very well and they can
sniff and the every time when they're
lying down the consideration is highly
on the caucus any mistake they can see
it before it happens they can read that
that one's gonna fall the time it drops
on the ground they are they already is
what has been happening here so you can
see that this cat must be very thirsty
or very tired because this Marla tree it
doesn't have quite a lot of broad
branches to support him one is seated
there so it's quite challenging is not
relaxed at the moment it's not
comfortable at all crazy this kind of
animals they Highness they've got a very
strong digestive system and also listen
to that you can see that these of
competition going on here and chasing
each other so these animals they've got
a very strong digestive system in order
to dissolve bones them and the
crocodiles as well as the pythons is one
of those animals who are well gifted so
these bones they are chewing here now
are not going to last much longer we are
going to see them on their droppings as
they are going to ten the color of the
droppings in two completely white due to
a lot of calcium on them
so that is the one who got the bigger
piece always trying to defend and chase
the other ones giraffe girl I am very
sure that when this cat lands on the
ground the first thing to do must be
going to the waterhole and then go for a
sleep
I'm sure waiting for this highness to go
away is also tiring for him he has been
there for quite a long time
but I don't think if he comes down here
this Highness are going to do him
anything maybe he's just thinking about
the other previous experiences he's not
holding any mates if he was having
something like I pray I was gonna say
they will chase him for that but now
there is no need for designers to chase
this catch look at that
what the reflection of the Sun this
looks beautiful so now let's go back to
Taylor on a guided walk still looking
for Tandy well
Tandy has gone waste basically in that
direction where the Sun is now about to
set and that's something that is of
course a bit problematic for us on Bush
Walker's that we are only able to stay
out during the the hours of daylight so
we've had to change direction slightly
we had our tracks crossing the road now
on her own Columbus tracks are not with
us which means that she's somewhere down
there and we actually heard some
Franklin's making a bit of an
interesting sound but like we've been
discussing her numbers unrelaxed on foot
so she's really running away from us and
I'm just trying to hide away so we're
checking on these big animal pathways as
you can see it makes it quite easy to
walk except when Craig has to get to
that lot of that tree that's growing out
of it there's gonna be a little bit on
that difficult side to get through
otherwise it's actually quite a nice
spot but it's very quickly going back
across the leopard up in the tree you
can see now that is getting an
opportunity there is running away from
the hyenas now that was interesting I
told you when he lands you on the ground
he must have to run you can see the
Highness are still going after him he's
going now up into another tree and we
are going to trap him again you can see
it's right there I'm just gonna reverse
now so that we can see what is gonna
happen they know
thank you very very much Heidi and our
past as such a lovely command to
Sebastian for his job well done
so our sauna knows very well that the
hyenas still wants to confirm if he is
running away with something or just
avoiding them so he's right here
Mik know that that is said dangerous
landing that must be a very dangerous
landing using Hina as a soft landing as
they can easily retaliate and they will
catch him you can see now he is right by
one of the branches it's not very far
away from the ground he knows very well
that way is now they cannot reach him so
he scanning is area now s a little chief
look at that he's working on the branch
s if he's on the ground he still doesn't
want to land on the ground
so you can see that now he is trying to
look everywhere because there is some
other stations as well having a sighting
with me and he is looking back at the
hyenas at the moment maybe is thinking
about two or three of them or twins them
is deciding where I can get water this
afternoon the hyenas are not that very
fast the leopards can be very very fast
the thing is Ines can go for a long
distance non-stop when they want to go
and catch something so they just keep
chasing so these ones can go very very
fast but also for a short spirit you can
see is now hitting much more towards the
tree house dam area so he must be going
for the afternoon drink now but if this
cat come across something he might catch
something I can promise you the cats
they are so very interesting they just
catch anything coming their way whether
they've got a kill or not
you can see that it's not worried about
anything all he's doing is just moving
so I'm just going to now carry on
following and see if we can have a
better sighting it has been lovely so
far
so he's walking very slowly so we just
gotta keep following and see way is
leading us to he's very very much in
relaxed at the moment so now let's go to
David by the Mara who's got some Lions
who are eating something well I still
have the Lions but before we look at
those lines again I want us to look at
that beautiful sunset and as I said
earlier luckily I had Manu on camera
today because there's one thing he never
misses to show me is when the Sun is
leaving us in this part of Africa who
not once watch that all the beautiful
and romantic and the most peaceful
colors you'd think of in your mind on
another evening like now and also am the
final contrast at his pretty standing
and we got a lioness I mean the male
lion was eating before I'm nauseous look
in the same direction enjoying the
sunset or it might have sensed some
strangers may be coming to sneak on your
kill and my guess is there's some other
predators because we're not very far
from the north clan the other predators
that anytime Lions make a hunt they'll
always try and come as much in their
food
at the Northland and waffles had moved
her Cubs to a new barrel but in
explicably she decided to move them back
to their original nest the Cape's
however seemed to have grown quite fond
of the new apartment the commander in
chief would not be defined with a firm
grip on the dominant cub she walks with
purpose for the second cub had no choice
but to follow closely behind once
relocated waffles made herself
comfortable while the young ones wasted
no time settling in for a feed well he
is still looking in a particular
direction and my only guess if anything
would worry him now could be highness we
are not very far from the North clan
group of highness and this is the area
they like roaming and the lairs clearly
no a combination of five six highness
that's a good number to come and snatch
this kill from them just wondering what
he is looking at and me and man were
looking we can't see anything but you
can tell he is looking at intent he has
focused in a particular direction the
only thing is so from a distance of an
ostrich and I don't think an ostrich
should be a concern to these two boys
here you have seen how why I call
waffles the commander-in-chief of the
Northland and most predators will always
carry their cubs by the neck and trying
to imagine maybe the neck doesn't you
know they can't had their cubs by the
neck in enough mass was just to have the
grip of your teeth there
gentlemen hyenas have so many ways of
communication but I think they're more
vocal than using their body language
like the tails Lions I know for a fact
they'll always use their tails when they
communicate and especially when they are
having a strategy to hunt
hyenas the lonely communicate using
their tails if there's a bit of
dominance you'll see how they just coil
I'll cook up the tail upwards and that's
always a clear message I'm in charge
here
so yes I would say they used their tails
once in a hall to communicate but at
night when you'd imagine is so dark the
earliest all y'all is very vocal
proud cat mama I can tell you they have
I mean lions have many many vocalization
and ideally the main ones is to
communicate if for example they have
lost touch with each other
we saw butternut on a clip when you'd go
and that's normally for the females and
that's when the 'trying made that to
look at to their cubs or to look at in
the main group as the sound they'll make
and for the males the main vocalizations
are either when they want to reestablish
the territories or what they think would
be having other males coming to their
territory
I'm not sure proud cat mama you can do
that but those are the two main ones but
once in a while I'm sure the other many
calls that you'll never pick up but
those two will be basically to relocate
each other in the pride and when males
need to command or just send a big roar
out there this is our territory and if
mama there could be a coalition of two
or three males they might go in stages
you might have the first one going and
then the second early come with a
different pitch and the third one and I
think the message they sent out there we
has so many Lions here please don't come
and play games and we own this area I do
not know until when those or these boys
will be able to roar like me if not
actually they're fully grown males like
a pulley man way you will him to roar
for me tonight are you able to do that
now
[Music]
well broadcast mama I don't know what
you think of man was raw but I think
it's not bad but I think man is still
young so I think he is trying to show
the way forward to these youngsters here
but the very big belly pull when you
hear them roar and if you happen to be
close to them back in my village because
those damn days we had Lions not very
far from where we still live even now a
friend of mine was telling me he had a
big male lion rolling but not very close
from where he was but he told me he
almost had like the ground was vibrating
and he could not even move anymore
because of the huge and loud roar from
that male lion he we established the
following morning when he went looking
at the trucks actually the lion was
about a mile away but the meantime let's
go across to asana I can see that now
husana is just right by the tree house
damn he is now having his drink and he
was also very much curious when coming
down here so I can tell you if anything
comes here he is going to take an action
look at that this is a normal behavior
the cat after having a meal they must
have to come down to the water holes and
have something so that they can be able
to quench their thirst is very hot in
the moment in the area the adoration is
very easy if they are not drinking they
are going to better to much with the
heat
that must be difficult and drinking from
the town so this town save quite a lot
of papers because it's the one that
these cats are using you know not to
scratch their heads when they catch a
prey so it has got some kind of a spines
it's like a sandpaper which helps them
in order to open the spaces in order to
get rid of desires before they eat
because the build up of this has in the
stomach gives them problems that's why
you will see some of them the able to
vomit some of the hair balls and you
will see them very big I have seen a
very big ball not long time ago on a
catwalk which was for the first time I
thought they can only create small balls
but sometimes they can even create
strings of desires
Hiroki that is very true
this animal is learning very quickly
because anytime soon is going to be
independent he must have to learn to
adapt all these other survival
strategies
and look at that so but I think it's
good that asana is depending a lot on
his own kill he's still very young
it won't be good for him to go and
scavenge after the other big males such
as ting Ghana he must have to give them
a chance they are old he has got quite a
lot of strength he can run fast he must
do hunting for himself
so the relationship between husana and
ting gana is very excellent at the
moment but as time goes on they are
going to look at each other like what we
are seeing there the reflection of the
eyes looking at tinker with it or sauna
drinking and big fights are just going
to take place Yash I've just lost the
operation something happens to my
communication if Emma can repeat that
question for me it is a glass that is
quite a very lovely comment I think at
this stage there's no need for that so
you can see that the nose is still very
pink which makes it very easy for me to
identify is nice and clean now doesn't
have blood anymore now I can identify or
sauna front in Ghana so now let's go
back to a Tristan now is now busy doing
some trekking activities around the
reserve we do indeed Sydney so while her
son is drinking Tammy is steadily mobile
as you can see she's on top of all the
places where they've dragged tires
during the course of today and I think
we quite far behind her this one dove
track that's on top otherwise her tracks
on top of everything else but she's
moving so far we are ready on Zuri's
Road we actually hitting down to where
all the boys are at the moment so I
wonder if she's not some way down that
area and he's kind of bout to hit the
hasana
ting ghana sighting so he just trying to
see where she goes from here Quan see if
she's carried on in the road no she's
gone off the side which means that she
must have gone
what are those tracks there no no she's
cut back over the road
she really is everywhere by the looks of
things it's just on top of this sort of
graded section I just want to check if
it's her or a hyena that's how you know
that's gone that way okay so she seems
to have cut off and maybe moved on this
side I just want to double-check where
she's going but I have a funny feeling
she's gonna go off the road here and
she's gonna head straight towards the
sort of full Aman's dip area pump ass
that's her general route so I want to
try and head in that direction as well
but I fear that we maybe have gotten
here too late we needed to get to this
point early this afternoon I reckon she
walked just about the time we started
game drive maybe a little bit before
that so it's but frustrating that we've
kind of so far behind her I was hoping
that we'd be much closer than what we
are so far I can't see where she's gone
from there did she cut back woody maybe
she went into the blocking waist and
didn't actually come south east
now it doesn't look like anything is
crossing this road I'm gonna go back to
that last track which is not ideal when
she's walking on the road it's quick and
easy and we can track fast but as soon
as she changes direction and cuts off
the road it becomes a bit of a problem
because but trying to kind of figure out
which way she goes and her movements
been so erratic but I'd be very
surprised if she went west she generally
doesn't go west at all her normal kind
of route is to come south from that
where those tracks are and to head down
towards for the ones area wonder what
Scott is so jumpy today that she's moved
so far she really has walked almost the
entire length and breadth of Juma at
this stage particularly if she ends up
going straight south like she has been
in kids past treehouse damn and you
never know now I'm just trying to see we
needed her tracks cut off Andy really
can be a tricky cat to find and we're
running out of light and that's the
biggest problem is if we had more lights
we would be able to find her a lot
easier not ideal right now okay I'm
gonna have a little look yeah see your
trucks are on the left so I just want to
see which way she actually goes and
while I do that did send you back across
to the bush for team well well we've
given up on trying to find attendee
because she's too far away from us and
we can't quite move at the speed is what
she is so we're back where we started at
Gallagher pan we're definitely not gonna
go searching port Colombo where we can
know where she is she's down in that
direction waiting for mom to come back
perhaps Tandy's on a bit of a
territorial Patrol she hasn't been doing
very many of those lately so it's best
that she comes and remarks here on the
western sector otherwise she do do I
think it's a well and open plot and
anyways no it's not just the lipids that
we've been chasing after but couple of
days ago the Inga rumor pride had me
going crazy
I knew something was up when I
eventually managed to track down the
Lions that have kept me up all night
long two piles of lions just lying off
the road but I didn't recognize the two
young boys who are severely affected by
mange the Inca Houma pride relying a few
feet away from them it turns out it's
the Hmong gained some adult males who
have had a rough life but that didn't
stop one of the Inca human lionesses she
growled and charged at the boys they
barely flinched
the Inca whom a pride eventually moved
off believing the man gained youngsters
to continue the hard road that is life
they seemed determined to keep up with a
pride interesting times lie ahead
what's jumping in the water it was me as
a statistic I'm frustrated because I
think Roma pride kept me out thirsty and
ad well very early in the morning it's
like 2 o'clock in the morning they were
here actually right yeah and they drank
water maybe we'll be able to find some
of their footprints but it has been a
bit windy it's been quite exciting
having the Lions come back I'm so sad
they weren't able to find themselves as
a buffalo because they walked all over
the buffalo tracks but they obviously
were just too too clever for them this
time around or perhaps they did try but
the Buffalo won because there's so many
of them could have chased them away but
this seems to be a very popular pattern
it's a pump pad so the lion sets yeah
they had a drink and then they actually
weren't too far away when we eventually
found them apnea mobile Road
but they didn't hang around too long
they were just cheerful was less than a
day narrating I found them in the
morning they did a massive loop really
really big loop all the way down south
to Chitra and then back and around and I
think that they're still on on Shirley's
from what I can understand the two young
sub-adult monkey and males are still
with them and keeping close quarters on
those lions right or you go back to the
Mara triangle to see what's happening
there
now I just found out these two
youngsters the attention was not the
high enough that I guessed before but
some vultures the vultures you see up
there a few of them started to descend
from the tree and trying to sneak on the
keel of these two youngsters here and
naturally the Lions having done such a
great job to bring down a wildebeest
they will not allow anybody to come and
snatch their meal but if there were a
Highness who'd say comfortable they
would easily come and grab the food from
them now one of them is still eating and
not the other
now talking about vultures we only saw
some two voltages that are called to do
the called elaborate phase vultures in
an urban vultures so there's so many
flies coming up here because of this
kill here and then I say they're about
seven other types of vultures or six
species of vultures in Kenya so want to
show you the other ones so the one on
top left up there that was good allama
gear always got a bearded vulture it's
an immature one it's fully grown there
they're almost extinct we still have a
few but not as many but this is not a
true vulture then there the vultures are
these ones you see here and the most
interesting one sorry I'm what about
that vulture the wingspan our Chris of
vultures could be anything up to three
meters sorry I got your question now the
wingspan of some of these vultures Chris
could be up to three meters but the
largest I mean the largest in terms of
you see that Ranmaru there so this one
here is what we just saw on that tree
there and it doesn't have as big
wingspan
I would guess as the one below this is a
person that we saw this called a nubian
vulture the lapis for vulture leopard
because you look carefully on the head
it's not covered by any feathers but
almost your size of wingspan this one
here manu
being slightly larger maybe by a few
inches a few centimetres but in terms of
flight one there that we called the
Rupa's Griffon vulture flyest highest
etre me not have a beak
during spawn Chris naked lap which one
but it applies the highest and the thing
could be the highest flying body in the
world
thirty five thirty seven thousand feet
like a jet so those are these six twelve
voters including the one we saw earlier
the lappet seven true vultures that we
got in Kenya the lapid fist the white
bucked the lap and then the troopers
Griffon vulture
and the palm not vulture and not
forgetting the hooded vulture which is
right here that's the who devotee right
there
very good now the lion is not stopping
to eat he still keeps eating as we go
back to find out the brother
but one of them still keeps looking in a
direction like something is coming but
whatever is coming or whatever he is
wary of I do not see and I do not know
what it is but I'm sure there could be
something and not sure if Hosanna is
equally worried like these two
youngsters here or this one particular
youngster that's not eating I can see
that now Hosanna is right up by the dam
all listening to what is happening in
the surrounding he is replying to every
call all the birds in the area is trying
to get the rest of the information about
who is in this area I can see that his
head is not settled than the es are
swiveling all the time he is right on
top and he is watching what is happening
from the ground
when the birds are calling beside is
checking when they are calling on the
other side is checking it's just
confused at the moment but looking at
way is now is on the road and a grass is
camouflaging him
Murphy husana will be able to take over
from his dad as soon as he retires I can
see that now instead of got quite a lot
of strength I saw that when he was now
defending the new girlfriend a few days
ago that was about a week ago and now
Hassan is skating gaining quite a lot of
strength and as time goes on he's going
to challenge him and push him out unless
another leopard comes with the strength
higher than Hassan and take over from
ting garner just like what has been
witnessed went in Ghana was not feeling
well when umph ocassi came to the area
and try to take over and when ting gana
got better then he left again you can
see that other males around this area
they're also opportunistic they are
waiting for the chance
so let's see what he's thinking a
rosalind that is very true indeed this
cat looks very beautiful look at that so
what I think
Tandi is the one who looks much more
beautiful than a horse on Danny looks
very beautiful with the specific
beautiful rosette sports
so now you can see Osama is thinking
about the darkness coming so that he can
do his hunting activities let's go back
to bush walk personas thinking about the
darkness that's a very unhappy bird
anyways and speaking of things that make
people unhappy I think hyenas reading
temps is probably quite high on a lot of
people who work in the Safari industries
list anyways so we haven't we actually
had an increase of hyena activity in and
around camp and that of course I think
is due to the fact that we have a new
hyena dinner on site and Corky has been
incredible Vicki she's almost been at
that den every single day watching Koki
and her cub that resembles a bear like
creatures stumble around the day is one
of the most precious sites we suspect
that the covers only in its second week
of life this means that a subtle latest
old Albany hokey has been a great mother
visiting the den regularly to sacrifice
angry cab however a little one is still
not sure of the outside world and often
scoots back to the den for safety
actually hyenas calling in the distance
which was pretty awesome and so we are
getting to that crepuscular period now
where everything is so interesting to
wake up the typically comes out at night
it's cooled down quite nicely I actually
think it's going to be a fairly chilly
evening so I'm gonna be listening out
this evening for any footsteps around
camp I'm not actually sure who's coming
into camp but with coquí's den not being
very far away
I reckon should be a regular visit along
visit along with auntie mo and ribbon
will be somewhere around here then I
also supposed to Aubrey who is one of
the guides at Juma and he said down on
Gallagher Road a couple of days ago
maybe about a week ago now he said he
saw four hyenas at an old dance site
that we used to visit down there so I
don't know what's happening but tomorrow
morning I'm definitely gonna head on
that way and see if I can see you nice
fresh signs of another day inside which
is pretty epic anyways the bush walk
team is running out of light now
Tristan is still hot on the heels of
Tandy well I don't know about hots on
the trail we've kind of throw in the
dice here because we're running out of
time so much and we really need to get a
little bit further heads to where she
might be we kind of jumped very far to
where I think she's gonna go and so the
route that she's taking is the one that
she takes when it comes through this
thicket on my left-hand side she runs
along the drainage and then she comes
out to Fulham on Stubbs so we've jumped
all the way to you Rebecca's for the
monster area and I'm just trying to see
now if I can find her the problem is the
light is really getting quite poor and
so spotting her is going to be really
tricky in this but we'll hopefully get
some luck I mean I think she's somewhere
between where we had the tracks and
where we are now whether she's moving or
she's stalking I don't know I think
she's possibly hunting and so it might
be a bit tricky to spot her but let's
see you never know like I say you gotta
roll the dice and if you want to be
successful and so hopefully we're gonna
get what we need so Tom generally with
leopards they leave their cubs only
after mating and when they actually
start to feel like they're pregnant then
they start to to sever that connection
some females maybe not so in salacious
case with tianni she left gianni long
before she even fell pregnant so it just
depends on the female it's difficult to
say I mean this always but different you
know obviously with Columbus she had
mated whilst she still had Humber still
went back to him before she actually
continued with you know mating and then
have been pregnant so it depends
sometimes they'll do
either or it just depends on conditions
and how things are at the time but oh it
imagined given Tandy's history when she
starts to mate that's kind of her way of
starting to push her youngster away and
and once she's pregnant then she has
nothing to do with that youngster very
quickly so we'll see how it goes
the Parkinson oh she is sherbet rated
two vehicles she's absolutely fine with
vehicles she's a little bit shy when
mom's not around and but otherwise she's
okay I've had many sightings we have
seen her either with me personally or
with other guides where she is quite
fine she doesn't seem to be too sort of
perturbed as long as you don't kind of
drive fast around her and you just give
her a bit of space she's actually quite
fine she doesn't really stress too much
at all so I don't think she's at in the
next day she's not a three-vehicle cat
yet but she'll hopefully you know become
that way as just gets a bit more
independence right well unfortunately we
run out of time we try to do one last
look but in the meantime that sends you
across to David so you can see what he's
up to tomorrow good luck for Tandy and
Columba I mean I've never forgotten the
Queen and the outside princess of Jummah
I haven't heard of them of late and
hopefully there might be found today
before we close the show
well the Lions would set leave them
behind and we come to the wildebeest and
find out the direction they are going
but to me the direction they are walking
to is where those two youngsters are and
as much as their full
we have known Lions even when the full
deal take any opportunity that comes
only away but it's getting pretty dark
here and we're coming almost to the end
of my time you know me and Manu is not
over yet because guys in Duma will be
continuing but I'd really want to thank
you for joining us and apologize for
having studied a bit late because of our
technical issues but to all of you have
a very lovely Sunday as you go back to
Hosanna
I am still here with a little chief and
the little chief is very very very much
relaxed at the moment I can see that the
little ship is not worried about
anything at the moment he's just here
resting on top of the dry on top of the
bank of the dam you can see there is not
that very far he's thinking about
something I must have to check now
oh these hyenas drinking at the dam
these are the Highness who are helping
this cat a lot because they are teaching
him how to climb a tree very quickly and
also how to climb down very quickly so
he must have to be thankful to these
hyenas sometimes because if he if he is
not treated like that it won't be able
to use his skills in order to go away
from danger as soon as possible so you
can see that now he is right looking at
the sinus
romance I didn't copy your questions
very nicely if mi can repeat that
question for me Robert
the lapis if you can check they don't
really have any kind of strange things
they are doing they are unlike the Lions
which normally win a battle and kill the
babies so this was the lepers they are
very much good to me I don't think
they've got anything bad so you can see
now the hyena is drinking there the
sinus makes a lot of noise when drinking
I can hear that noise from here
so the highness they also profess to
come down here and just play when they
are cleaning themselves so not all only
bears it has done even the highness
their armors that deal with Koreans for
them to get rid of that smell
they've gonna have to come here early in
the mornings and sometimes late in the
afternoon these days is also happening
during the day I have seen it by the
twins damn so they were only animal I
haven't seen doing that is the lepers
other leopards I think the shade is good
enough to cool their body temperature
and they can only use you look at that
now you can see that Ryan has got some
lot of blood here on the neck unless
it's just a reflection you can see this
are their blood that whatever falling
from the carcass to these animals so you
can see that the little chief is sure
that this Hina is gone it has been a
very lovely afternoon with quite a lot
of four sightings from Mara we saw
lovely Lions there and we also saw
interaction of the Highness and the
lepers here in Duma where the lepers two
leopards were just close to each other
and let's meet again tomorrow morning